bonjour a tous invités de sark l'a dit
ce matin le politologue jean claude
williams bonjour bon aloi
allez-y bonjour bonjour à lagnieu risque
usées mois et à toutes
voilà alors avec vous nous aborderons
les la politique française et les enjeux
de l'élection présidentielle mais aussi
on nous allons également parlé des
législatifs en martinique alors le
président hollande ne se représente pas
ces manuels vase qui sera candidat de la
primaire du ps
quelles sont ses chances de rassembler
la gauche pour faire le ps déjà mais
il ya une vraie difficulté dans
la mesure où il ya déjà je ne sais pas
combien de candidats et il y a notamment
les ce qu'on appelle les frondeurs qui
en plus d'ailleurs sont en ordre
dispersé puisque il ya de mémoire il ya
à nos moules bourg qui fait pour
l'instant parmi les frondeurs la course
en tête
d'après les sondages il y à benoît
moulias marie noëlle mal il y à girard
fils ash et jeanne oui certainement et
le candidat valls avait déclaré il est
déjà quelque temps qu'il y avait deux
gauches irréconciliables
c'est une complication dans son discours
de déclaration de candidature elle
indiqué qu'au contraire il était le
candidat de la réconciliation
je crois qu'il aura du mal à convaincre
ses anciens camarades de ses bonnes
dispositions et on a vu que monsieur on
our en particulier lui a répondu assez
sèche tout à fait il lui a parlé notant
du 49-3 fait de son bilan lui alors cela
dit cela dit la campagne pour la
primaire socialiste ne fait que
commencer et valls est un homme de
ressources de talent il n'est pas
impossible qu'il a eu finalement à
réconcilier une partie de la gauche avec
une difficulté supplémentaire ce qu' il
n'est pas du tout sûr que la liste des
candidats à la primaire socialiste soit
close tout à fait on évoque beaucoup
nicolas lieu de christiane taubira là à
mon avis christiane taubira envie d'y
aller c'est évident
mais je crois encore elle et qu'elle
n'ira pas il ya une sorte de commandes
rsa de conjuration des femmes des femmes
qui soutiennent les valeurs de la gauche
avec eux martine aubry christiane
taubira qui apparemment se seraient
mises d'accord pour promouvoir la
candidature d'une autre femme qui est
populaire qui fait du bon travail qui en
plus un nom prestigieux dans les milieux
intellectuels c'est marisol touraine et
par conséquent aussi madame touraine est
candidate
ça va encore compliquer le jeu et par
conséquent réduire aussi c'est l'espace
l'espace de valse de tôle que sur sa
droite je suis lire même assurance à
gauche extrême il y à jean luc mélenchon
mais c'est quand même c'est quand même
inédit le fait d'avoir autant d'anciens
ministres d'un gouvernement de plusieurs
gouvernements successifs et la france ya
vincent peillon qui vient d'annoncer que
ce sera candidat c'est quand même une
i10 qu'est ce que cela traduit et
s'écouter ce qu'il dit bien sûr mais
cela veut dire aussi que le que les
temps changent et que en réalité nous
sommes dans une période compliquée qui
fait que l'ailé les projets sont
difficiles à déterminer
parce que précisément les données ne
sont plus les mêmes il ya plus de
candidat naturel vient pas de candidat
naturel d'une paris puis notre part uwe
seeler les définitions des projets
d'avenir ne sont pas si facile que cela
la droite d'ailleurs on parle beaucoup
maintenant le la confusion à gauche mais
il ya encore quelques semaines
la confusion était à droite il y avait
aussi beaucoup de candidats et puis
finalement au bout du compte elle
inquiète sortie est celui qui est sorti
c'est celui qui précisément propose les
mesures les plus radicales si je puis
dire mais radicale à droite
des mesures que l'un de ses concurrents
monsieur juppé avait qualifié de brutale
d'une grande brutalité économique et
social alors je crois que c'est
compliqué de se trouver une un cap pour
l'avenir c'est vrai aussi bien pour la
droite que pour la gauche ce qui fait
que chacun a sa petite solution et qu'il
entend la faire connaître
on va parler on va revenir
sur les enjeux de l'élection après mais
est ce que le risque pour la gauche pour
le ps d'un côté pour la gauche toute
entière ce n'est pas seulement de perdre
les élections mais c'est aussi deux se
voient devoir réduire à peau de chagrin
son nombre de députés à l'assemblée
nationale au registre civil en citerai
exemple ce n'est que nous sommes dans un
système qui est le parlementarisme
majoritaire c'est à dire que nous sommes
en national il y à une majorité qui est
faite de gens qui soutiennent la
position du président de la république
par conséquent si on prend l'hypothèse
la plus vraisemblable aujourd'hui à
l'heure où nous parlons
la campagne crise ne fait que commencer
par conséquent je vais bien indiquer les
choses aujourd'hui en tout cas
l'hypothèse la plus vraisemblable c'est
que monsieur fillon soit le nouveau
président je n'aurais pas dû insiste
aujourd'hui oui le 7 décembre 2016 cette
fois ci se passera et énergique parfois
les sondages doors est dans cette
hypothèse là je crois qu'il est tout à
fait évident que la gauche sera réduite
à la portion congrue
parce que fillon rapidement une majorité
de députés se réclamant de lui et par
conséquent que la droite les
républicains vont accroître les
circonscriptions qui pour certaines sont
détenues aujourd'hui par les socialistes
ou par leur ailier et avec en embuscade
marine le pen avait gravi ce cas de
marine le pen je crois que le cadenas il
ne peut être un cas tout à fait
intéressant parce que marine le pen est
arrivé à modifier très largement l'image
du village de son père mais elle n'est
pas arrivée totalement ce qui veut dire
que en réalité marie le pen s'il est
vrai le longtemps on disait du père le
pen qui était un homme politique de
protestataires ils protestaient il
portait la protestation bon et que par
conséquent il n'avait pas il ne
cherchait pas non plus avoir vertement
l'adhésion des citoyens
madame le pen cherche à voir la légion
mais en continuant malgré tout à tenir
un discours qui est un discours
d'exclusion vis-à-vis d'un certain
nombre de gens
qui vivent en france et avec les valeurs
qui ne sont pas des valeurs
démocratiques en classe est perçu comme
cela il est vrai aussi qu'elle rassemble
toute une sorte une série de déçus de la
gauche d'abord déçu les communistes de
l'est sud est socialiste et par
conséquent elle a hélas un fonds
électoral important mais ce fonds
électoral ne lui permet pas au jour
d'aujourd'hui d'arriver à avoir 50 % des
voix par conséquent de gagner l'élection
moi je crois à lorp les spécialistes ont
un langage un peu particulier il parle
de plafond de verre elle ne peut pas
dépasser betton 35 % je crois que c'est
encore vrai aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
ce qui se passera à la prochaine
présidentielle
mais au jour d'aujourd'hui je crois que
madame le pen sortira première du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle mais elle sera battue
quel que soit le candidat qu'elle raouf
en face
alors parlons maintenant des
législatives en martinique une
circonscription concentre tous les
regards il s'agit de celle du centre
atlantique
alfred marie-jeanne le député sortant ne
se représente pas les enjeux sont
importants pour le mime
je ne crois pas à la demande il serait
utile et intéressant pour le mime qu'ils
gardent ou colombie - de ses alliés
caron plus mais beaucoup la guerre
maintenant et il est il est par
conséquent intéressant politiquement
important que le mime garde la
circonscription je sais pas essentiel le
le jeu n'est pas là le jeu c'est à la
collectivité territoriale c'est là le
vrai enjeu le député on le voit le plus
en plus aujourd'hui
le député c'est en était le porte parole
des intérêts martiniquais au sens le
plus large du terme
le député un rôle précisément 2 il
attire l'attention il appelle
l'attention muselier qui détient les
clés du pouvoir
et bien c'est celui qui gère la
collectivité aujourd'hui la côte hill
territoriale et je ne crois pas je crois
que l'uimm pure à tout pour garder la
circonscription
mais s'il arrivait qu'il la perde ce ne
serait pas une catastrophe
produit pour le leem pour le mime
d'accord autres circonscriptions on va
rapidement si celle du
du nord 2 le maire de sète mari bruno
nestor azérot en tant que député sortant
doit se représenter pour garder sa
circonscription s combien est-ce que
c'est une circonscription verte
mais vu des choix que c'est un peu un
peu le même problème je ne crois pas
quatre députés se sont tout à fait
essentiel pour monsieur à 0 ça l'est
peut-être
et n'oublions pas qu'il ya une sorte du
dicton qui veut que qui détient sainte
marie la commune de sainte-marie détient
nécessairement la circonscription du
nord
moi je crois à 20 s'il faut s'en tenir
aux dernières déclarations de monsieur
de monsieur à 0 aurait quand même un
penchant pour rester dans sa commune et
par conséquent et s'est ouverte laissée
ouverte la section législatives et
tantôt ne servait qu'il y aura
certainement un candidat mr six hôtels
où william bonne journée à tous ça au
cas déterminé